Nevada may be known for the excitement
and entertainment of Las Vegas but it's
the quieter less flashy state capital
Carson City that's making headlines for
the first time in our nation's history a
state legislature has a majority of
female lawmakers 51% or women far
exceeding the roughly 15% of such states
as Mississippi in West Virginia Jamie
yuccas talked with some of Nevada is a
new majority who are pushing for change
in the halls of Nevada State Capitol
it's hard not to notice there's a wave
of women there are young women who look
at the wall of our country's presidents
and think well no one looks like me and
they can look to Nevada and say wow so
many of them look like me
senator Ivana Kinsella says the new
majority has propelled female focus
legislation she's behind a bill passed
earlier this month protecting a woman's
access to abortion and removes the
requirement of asking whether she's
married or not women all over the
country said I'm tired of taking the
backseat to having other people make
decisions about my body about my
children about my life about my
workplace I want to be in that
decision-making seat Pat Spearman one of
the longest-serving state senators first
took office in 2013 she says many of the
bills passing are topics that naturally
arise when women are at the table the
women who are here this time doesn't
matter which party when we're passionate
about something we just push for it
bills introduced this session tackled
issues like sex trafficking sexual
misconduct equal pay and child marriage
Republican Assemblywoman Melissa Hardy
and her Democratic colleague Selena
Torres have worked across the aisle to
better education I think it has been the
most incredible experience of my life I
know we have over 90 percent
bipartisanship on the book bills that we
passed so far you're agreeing on
something Torres is a 23 year old
teacher hardy is a mom and business
owner but where they can build bonds
they do especially outside capital walls
the things that we share are a lot more
than the things that differences that we
have and so you
go out you do you have fun you have
dinner you see so I did have a band in
my younger years I have a stage name now
and everything what's your stage name
they call me Marty
the gatherings in committee and outside
of it keep getting bigger with 51% of
the majority these women say their only
objective is to serve every Nevadan the
idea of having a female majority has as
left a sense of pride that I can't even
explain to you you're a fighter I am I
am I don't know anything else to do but
fight and I hope when I leave here one
of the things that they will say about
me is that she fought and never gave up
for CBS this morning Saturday Jamie
yuccas Carson City Nevada nothing wrong
with that it's about time it's about and
that's why we love you and we're in
better hands now right yeah they are in
Nevada